all right really let's be honest with
ourselves of anyone in the movie Titanic
Best Supporting Actor goes with that guy
who hit the propeller on the way down
talked about stealing the show that guy
Titanic in 3d right so it has been years
since I've seen Titanic last time I saw
Titanic I hated Titanic cuz I wanted to
hate Titanic because I was a really
greasy haired City face nerd and every
girl in the world wanted to use
DiCaprio's face as a bicycle seat I just
didn't like that I was like what what's
wrong with my little greasy city face it
makes a fine bicycle see I mean look at
this nose you you think about the
possibilities but now I have once again
seen James Cameron's Titanic so the
movie Titanic is pretty much exactly
what it sounds like it's a movie about
the ship Titanic which sinks and on the
ship are a few fictional characters one
of which is ROS played by Kate Winslet
she's engaged to Billy Zane more on that
guy later and she hates her life you
know because she's just surrounded by a
bunch of really pretentious rich people
who are all like Leo Vonda stock
exchange yes but in which she then meets
jack played by young Leonardo DiCaprio
who's this fun free spirit kind of guy
he's really poor he's third class on
Titanic they call them steerage it just
sounds really spit on doesn't it and
through situational circumstance the two
team up they start building a romance
and for the first hour and a half of
this movie it is straight-up
romance and in that aspect of the movie
the formula is pretty basic
you got your one chick engaged to this
one guy she doesn't like her life she
doesn't like him then he have the other
guy who's the really fun guy he's gonna
teach her everything that she's been
missing about the world but they're from
two completely separate worlds if you
feel like you've seen it before you have
so have i but it works and Cameron does
a good job at getting you on their side
you know you're like I like your guys's
romance I feel like you're building
something she didn't annoy the out
of me she was actually a pretty fun
chick she's just confined by all the
douchebags all the old rich people on
the Titanic who control her life who
were part of the Academy then and are
probably still part of the Academy like
today yeah those big let's talk about
her fiance played by Billy Zane in this
movie cuz oh my god Billy Zane in
Titanic is pretty much one of the
biggest dicks of 90s movies seriously
the dude totally kills it in this movie
he's a complete he was like a
complete douchebag before the
ship was sinking after the ship sinking
everyone's like alright every man for
himself it's all about numeral you know
me he was ahead of the curve
man he was always like that in this
movie like this ship the Titanic is
sinking there not enough lifeboats for
everybody best-case scenario half the
people on the ship are gonna die
Billy's ain't just like not the better
half it's like you oh you you did you
went there you totally Wow
people like that exist that's why I'm
just like floored by that kind of stuff
and among this love story elements some
of the dialogue is cheesy there's no
denying that you know I'm not even
talking about the whole like I'm the
king of the world thing I'm talking
about what she's like I'm flying some of
the cap Rio's reaction shot through his
like a little odd little corny I'm
telling you guys it's the guy who hits
the propeller on the way down brings it
all home but then the movie completely
changes the moment you hear the phrase
iceberg right egg we're now in survival
mode the ship hits the iceberg spoilers
for anyone who never went to elementary
school and doesn't know that and now the
ship is gradually going to sink in chaos
is going to ensue I love this this is
humanity at its finest and by finest I
mean lowest low because when you have a
bunch of people on a ship at first like
all right orderly fashion get into the
boats everyone gets into the lifeboats
and all seems like it might be fine with
the world then everyone starts figuring
out that wait a minute I don't think I'm
gonna live through this I'm probably
gonna die in which case survival of the
fittest doesn't quite cover it people do
shout they do shout hard it doesn't even
make sense you guys some people like
cutting ropes to life rafts I don't even
know what that's gonna accomplish but it
made sense to them because they're like
well it's either this or we die this is
probably gonna help me die but I'm gonna
do it anyway going down into the icy
waters of the Atlantic things that you
do are probably not gonna make sense got
people jumping from the ship which is
really funny because they're like oh the
ships sinking I don't want the ship to
sink I don't want to have to go into the
water because that's what will happen if
I go down with the ship so I'm just
gonna jump into the water I'll end up
exactly where the ships gonna take me
but that makes sense to me right now so
let's jump I just love the slow swell of
chaos at this point everything is just
so extreme it really looks like this
enormous Titanic ship is actually
sinking into the ocean
and it gets faster and fast from the
emotional level of everybody it starts
rising people start doing stuff man they
start throwing people off they start
shooting people they start shooting
themselves it's a riot on a ship yeah it
would happen just like that and I have
no doubt the actual event was probably a
lot like that when people are faced with
their inevitable
they don't stay still I mean really
whatever you know about yourself if
you're on a ship it's gonna sink and you
are probably going to die because of it
I mean what would you do I'm sure the
answer is going to be different for
everybody but I can guarantee this the
answer will not be I would sit calmly in
an orderly fashion and wait for the
authorities that would last like 15
minutes some of the special effects did
look a bit dated at this point but
actually give James Cameron the balls
for not correcting everything I may be
really easy to Lucas out on this it is
the same movie now that it was in 97
when it came out except for the
converted 3d I mean did the movie have
to be converted into 3d I don't think so
but the converted 3d in Titanic is not
only better than any converted 3d movie
I've ever seen but it's better than a
lot of other movies that are shot by Joe
Blow director filming in 3d who doesn't
know how to which goes to show you if
you know how to use 3d than use 3d if
you don't don't do anything with 3d
don't film it don't convert it just make
a movie did I cry in Titanic
you betcha I mean let's be honest with
ourselves in the movie Titanic a diamond
that's about as big as my fist ends up
at the bottom of the Atlantic oh it
always is the money
cried like a baby at that little fact so
is it a puppy love romance yes it
absolutely is it's the movie a hardcore
survival movie about what people do when
they're faced with their inevitable
death amongst a catastrophe you betcha
and does a guy fall from the Titanic and
smack a propeller and spin as he hits
the ocean yes it does it do all of these
well yes it does if for nothing else I
can say I'm actually excited that
Titanic was re-released because I'm
thinking soon it's gonna be released on
blu-ray because I myself would buy
Titanic on blu-ray love story or the
absurd rising fire of chaos whatever you
like about it you'll like something in
Titanic so your favorite James Cameron
movie out there of all of them what is
it comment below let me know some of you
are gonna say piranhas who
aren't you I know you are I said it for
you so now if you say it it's not
original you can still say it if you
want to only it'll be a little
disappointing and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you